nous sommes réunis en application de
l'article L 14 51-1 du code incendie
publique qui prévoit l'audition par les
commissions compétentes du Parlement des
présidents directeurs et directeurs
généraux d'institutions visé à
différents articles du même code avant
leur nomination par l'exécutif nous
entendons donc aujourd'hui madame
Caroline semailles candidate proposée
aux fonctions de directrice générale de
l'Agence nationale de santé publique
autrement dit santé publique France
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat
comme je l'ai fait pour l'audition de la
future directrice générale de l'agence
de la biométrie je voudrais rappeler que
la vie de vacances pour le poste de
directeur général de l'Agence nationale
de santé publique France a été publié le
27 juillet 2022 que le poste est wagon
vacant depuis la fin octobre et que nous
n'avons été saisi que très récemment de
cette demande d'audition mais vous n'y
pour rien
après la crise sanitaire on ne présente
plus santé publique France qui a par
ailleurs fait l'objet d'une enquête de
la Cour des comptes qui nous a été
remise récemment notre commission est
particulièrement attentive aux missions
d'agence sont financement ainsi qu'à ses
relations avec cette tutelle le
ministère de la Santé la réflexion en
cours sur la réforme du ministère
devrait également avoir des implications
sur les dispositifs d'alerte et de
veille sanitaires auxquels nous serons
attentifs
je vous laisse donc la parole pour
présenter votre parcours les enjeux que
vous identifiez pour l'agence et la
façon dont vous entendez y répondre
madame sommeil à vous madame la
présidente Madame la rapporteur général
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateur ma candidature à la direction
de santé publique France qui vous est
proposée par le gouvernement me donne
l'honneur d'être entendu par notre
commission celle-ci a produit de
nombreux travaux sur le rôle des agences
sanitaires mais aussi sur les enjeux
majeurs de santé publique j'ai moi-même
au cours de ces dernières années eu la
chance de contribuer au développement
des trois principaux opérateurs de cette
écosystème sanitaire j'y reviendrai dans
le cadre de mon propos actuellement
directrice générale adjointe depuis
presque deux ans à la NSM agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
des produits de santé j'ai acquis au
cours des 20 dernières années au sein
des trois agences sanitaires une assez
large expérience de la gestion de crise
des politiques de santé publique de la
démocratie sanitaire du management
et de la gestion d'établissements
publics à vocation d'expertise dans le
domaine de la santé et de
l'environnement c'est sur ces bases
ainsi que sur l'ensemble de mon parcours
professionnel que ce fond de ma
candidature au poste de Directrice
Générale de Santé Publique France je
suis médecin de santé publique praticien
hospitalier épidémiologiste et consacrer
les 10 premières années de ma vie
professionnelle aux maladies
infectieuses en particulier à la lutte
contre le VIH SIDA afin de soutenir des
projets en prévention dans le cadre de
mission d'appui ou d'émission
humanitaires
parallèlement une activité clinique
pratiquée durant plus de 15 ans j'ai
rejoint en 2000 l'Institut de Weiss
sanitaire aujourd'hui santé publique
France en tant que médecin
épidémiologiste en charge de la
surveillance du VIH des IST et des
hépatites pendant ces 10 années
j'animais en fait une équipe à la
frontière entre la surveillance et la
recherche où j'ai développé des systèmes
de surveillance innovants mis en place
des enquêtes auprès des populations
vulnérables telles que les populations
carcérales ou les populations usagées de
drogue titulaire d'une habitation à
diriger des recherches j'ai aussi
conservé des fonctions d'encadrement et
d'enseignement pendant plusieurs années
dans le cadre de mes fonctions j'étais
également très engagées dès le début des
années 2000 dans le dialogue avec les
associations de patients donc ce
dialogue engagé avec aide avec Act-Up
notamment
sont finalement précurseurs de
l'ouverture à la société civile que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
en décembre 2013 j'ai rejoint à la NSM
en tant que directrice produit à la tête
d'une équipe pluridisciplinaire j'ai
notamment contribué en 2018 à définir
les conditions de réussite de la
politique vaccinale chez les nourrissons
concertation publique information
transparente ont contribue à restaurer
la confiance et l'adhésion des familles
à cette politique de santé publique
j'ai toujours conservé un lien avec
l'expertise en santé publique et une
sensibilité aux questions déontologiques
ainsi j'ai été membre du Haut Conseil de
santé publique et participer aussi à la
Commission nationale de déontologie des
alertes en matière de santé publique et
d'environnement la Cnaps
forte de ces expériences en matière de
santé humaine et de management j'ai été
nommée en 2019 directrice générale
déléguée de landeces l'Agence nationale
de sécurité sanitaire de l'alimentation
de l'environnement et du travail je
dirige alors une équipe de 350 personnes
et j'étais en charge de l'évaluation des
produits phyto pharmaceutiques biocide
et je supervisais l'activité de l'agence
nationale des médicaments vétérinaires
les dossiers que j'ai eu très à traiter
à lances mêlée intimement les questions
de santé humaine de santé animale et de
santé environnementale je retiens de
cette expérience notamment l'importance
du dialogue avec les parties prenantes
en particulier sur des sujets à forte
dimension de controverse évidemment les
enjeux environnementaux ou analys
j'ai aussi été amené à contribuer à de
nombreuses crises sanitaires qui ont
marqué ces 20 dernières années le strass
le H1 le merkov Ébola en 2014 et plus
récemment évidemment covid dès mars 2020
je suis venu en appui pendant quelques
mois à la recherche auprès de Réactine
Inserm réactive Inserm aujourd'hui est
devenu la NRS et milieu qui est un
partenaire privilégié de santé publique
France c'est toujours en pleine crise
sanitaire en avril 2021 que j'ai rejoint
mes anciens collègues de la NSM au poste
de directrice générale adjointe en
charge des opérations et donc en charge
d'une équipe de 800 personnes outre les
enjeux liés à l'évaluation et la
surveillance en vie réelle des vaccins
et des traitements covid la NSM est
garant d'un cadre assurant le même
niveau d'exigence sur chacune des 80 000
autorisations
délivrer chaque année grâce à la
collégialité de l'expertise un cadre
déontologique strict une transparence et
un dialogue permanent avec les parties
prenantes
c'est donc mon parcours professionnel
puis met 20 dernières années au sein de
ces trois grandes agences sanitaires qui
m'amènent aujourd'hui devant vous pour
poursuivre mon engagement au service de
l'intérêt général à la tête de santé
publique France
santé publique France
occupe une position particulière dans
mon parcours vous l'aurez compris mais
surtout au sein de l'écosystème
sanitaire c'est l'agence qui surveille à
décrit la santé de 67 millions de
Français qui identifient les risques qui
menacent leur santé c'est une agence qui
accompagne les Français au travers
d'action de prévention et de promotion
de la santé c'est une agence qui éclaire
les décideurs apportent son expertise y
compris aux autres institutions mais à
disposition des données de santé robuste
au travers notamment de l'Observatoire
cartographique Géode en 2021 ce sont 18
millions de visiteurs qui ont consulté
la plateforme Géode c'est une agence qui
contribue aussi à soutenir le système de
santé par la mobilisation de la réserve
sanitaire et assure la gestion des
stocks stratégiques grâce à
l’établissement pharmaceutique ce sont
plus de 200 millions de doses de vaccins
qui ont été distribués en métropole et
outre-mer
l'agence s'appuie sur des compétences
variées des équipes implantées dans
toutes les régions et sur des
dispositifs de surveillance multiple des
grandes enquêtes des outils de
prévention du marketing social et des
services d'aide à la distance ces
dispositifs de surveillance multisources
ont montré leur performance pendant leur
crise sanitaire mais il faut les
moderniser les fiabiliser les dotées
d'un schéma distracteur ainsi que la
relevée le récent rapport de la Cour des
comptes rappelons que SPF et ses
partenaires ont réussi à un temps record
des systèmes d'information pour la
gestion de crise sur lequel bien sûr il
faut capitaliser créer des systèmes
pérennes connectés et interopérable
santé publique France sont aussi des
grandes enquêtes dont les résultats
éclairent l'état de santé des Français
je pense à l'étude sur le bien-être des
centres de le bien-être des enfants de
moins de 11 ans je pense aussi à l'étude
canari sur l'improviation de la
population antillaise par le chlore des
cônes ou aussi au baromètre santé qui
sont ces études répétées depuis 30 ans
qui constituent le véritable
observatoire de l'évolution des
comportements des Français ces études
sont indispensables pour nourrir les
politiques publiques et évaluer leur
efficacité les données issues de la
surveillance des enquêtes permettent de
suivre les déterminants de santé de
décrire le fardeau lit à chaque
pathologie et contribue à orienter les
mesures de prévention et de promotion de
la santé incarnant ainsi le continuum de
l'agence de la connaissance à l'action
de la surveillance à la prévention
SPF n'est pas la seule à intervenir dans
le champ de la prévention elle fait
partie d'un vaste réseau d'acteurs
institutionnels ou associatif avec en
chef de fil bien entendu le ministère de
la santé et de la prévention
l'enjeu pour l'agence et de concentrer
ses efforts sur des interventions
efficaces évaluées il peut s'agir
d'intervention que l'agence conduit en
direct ou non c'est le cas de dispositif
basé sur des référentiels comme
nutrisccor c'est aussi SPF qui anime
héberge le Régis français des
interventions efficaces et prometteuse
en prévention et promotion de la santé
l'agence dispose donc d'un large
périmètre qui est la traduction d'une
volonté née en 2016 de doter notre pays
d'une agence de santé publique forte
scientifiquement et incarnant le
continuum de la connaissance à l'action
de la surveillance à la prévention
cela confère à la direction générale une
responsabilité que j'entends assumée
pleinement si vous m'accordez votre
confiance éclairez la décision publique
et le citoyen sur la base d'expertise et
de donner scientifiques et favoriser les
événements les environnements favorables
à la santé de tous pour mener à bien ses
missions l'agence a besoin de moyens je
préciserai à ce propos que j'ai bien
pris connaissance que la Cour des
comptes dans son récent en rapport à
relever qui conviendrait que le
Parlement dispose d'une information
précise sur les projections budgétaires
ce à quoi je souscris également
le budget de santé publique France a été
adapté aux besoins de la crise il était
de 4,5 milliards d'euros en 2022 dont
250 millions sur les missions socle hors
covid mais les moyens restent contraints
comme ceux de l'État notamment en ce qui
concerne les effectifs compte tenu des
enjeux sanitaires de son périmètre et
des attentes toujours plus fortes les
effectifs pour être quasiment illimités
mais nous savons que tal ne peut pas
être le cas dès lors l'agence va
entretenir des relations de confiance
avec sa tutelle de manière à bien
conduire ces missions au regard des
arbitrages rendus et la direction
générale quant à elle doit également
agir en manager attentive à ses équipes
faire des choix hiérarchisés et garder
un difficile équilibre entre les sujets
chauds et les sujets froids
je souhaiterais ici devant la
représentation nationale rendre un
hommage appuyé à ces femmes et hommes de
santé publique qui ont construit cette
agence et qui s'en relâche depuis trois
ans on luttait contre le covid je pense
en particulier au déploiement en temps
réel de la surveillance la production
quotidienne d'indicateurs des centaines
de millions d'os de vaccins qui
disponibles en tout point du territoire
les enquêtes sur l'impact hors covid et
notamment l'alerte donnée sur la santé
mentale des Français les affiches
dépliants campagnes diffusées dans toute
la France la traque des variants les
décryptages auprès de la presse
c'est donc également pour mes futurs
collaborateurs que je suis devant vous
ici car j'aspire à contribuer à donner
un sens au travail de chacun à
consolider la communauté de travail au
sein de santé publique France et
apporter les valeurs qu'ils incarnent
pour y parvenir trois priorités pour
résumer mes objectifs de mandat
ma première priorité une expertise
indépendante collégiale au service des
politiques publiques santé publique
France est une agence scientifique dont
les travaux d'expertise viennent en
appui les politiques publiques de la
surveillance à la prévention c'est avant
tout la science qui fonde ses travaux et
ses interventions elle doit s'appuyer
sur une expertise pluridisciplinaire
collégiale que ça soit pour l'expertise
interne très robuste à santé publique
France ou sur l'expertise externe ce
qu'elle produit doit être utile aux
politiques publiques et traduisible en
décision en levier d'action
son organisation avec un niveau national
et celle 16 cellules régionales placées
auprès des ARS doit être confortée car
c'est ainsi que l'agence pourra adopter
son action aux particularités
territoriales deuxième priorité c'est
faire de santé publique France une
agence ouverte c'est le gage de gagner
en visibilité et en crédibilité
l'ouverture c'est le développement des
collaborations avec des partenaires dont
le périmètre d'action sont aux
frontières avec celles de santé publique
France comme SPF l'a engagé avec
landeces sur l'exposition aux substances
chimiques ou lors de la future enquête
conjointe comme SPF l'a déjà engagé avec
l'INSERM la rsmie le hesp dans le
domaine de la santé sexuelle de la
pérennité ou de la santé des
travailleurs
des collaborations spécifiques sont
nécessaires également avec la recherche
sur des questions intéressantes
directement l'agence sur les maladies
émergentes ou sur la modélisation c'est
d'ailleurs ensemble que santé publique
France et la NRS est mieux ont porté la
création du consortium émergents
pays d'une capacité de ses cancers hors
normes pour surveiller les variants du
covid santé publique France ne dispose
pas comme l'ancêtre de moyens propres de
financement de recherche mais l'agence
doit pouvoir adresser ces questions à la
recherche elle doit interagir
étroitement avec la recherche
il s'agit aussi de renforcer l'ouverture
de l'agence et le dialogue avec les
parties prenantes la société civile mais
également les professionnels de santé et
les acteurs du secteur médico-social ils
sont des acteurs clés de la prévention
nous nous appuierons aussi sur eux pour
déployer la feuille de route du
ministère
il s'agit aussi de contribuer à la
diffusion d'information scientifiques
adaptées à tous les publics c'est ainsi
que nous pourrons lutter contre la
diffusion de fausses informations et de
restaurer la confiance
sur le plan européen et l'international
l'agence doit poursuivre l'impulsion
donnée par la précédente directrice
générale une troisième priorité je
voudrais une agence en fait qui anticipe
qui n'offre c'est l'analyse des signaux
précoces par exemple au travers des
systèmes multisources et du travail en
réseau c'est développer les approches
qualitatives mais c'est aussi l'analyse
des données massives en santé en
partenariat avec les autres institutions
au travers notamment du elsae ou du
crime data hub et c'est aussi poursuivre
la mise à thèse position en Open Data
des centaines d'indicateurs
ou sortir ou sortir de ces trois années
de covid je souhaite aux côtés de tous
les agents de santé publique France
donner un élan fort immobilisateur à
l'agence une agence d'expertise de haut
niveau ouverte au partenariat aux
parties prenantes et à l'innovation
je souhaite enfin que santé publique
France reste à la disposition de votre
commission je considère éclairer la
représentation nationale fait partie du
rôle de l'agence et du mien je me
livrais à cet exercice chaque fois que
j'essaierai invité je vous remercie
merci beaucoup Chantal de Seine des
questions
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
pour la présentation de votre parcours
quelques questions le la Cour des
comptes avait présenté devant notre
commission en décembre dernier son
rapport et à insister sur les lacunes
des systèmes de surveillance de veille
sanitaires en particulier dans le
domaine dans le secteur médico-social
comment envisagez-vous c'est important
chantier de modernisation
une autre question et vous avez fait
allusion de votre propos le Sénat avait
relevé également en 2020 l'inadaptation
aux crises du dispositif de la réserve
sanitaire comment selon vous faudrait-il
moderniser son cadre d'action ou sa
gestion administrative pour faire face
aux crises futures
et puis peut-être une dernière question
sur la prévention et la promotion de la
santé la Cour relève toujours un défaut
de stratégie globale discuter au conseil
d'administration conduisant à ce que
certains chants restent absents des
préoccupations de lagence telles que la
santé mentale la santé des personnes
âgées ou encore les accidents
vasculaires cérébraux comment
envisagez-vous de couvrir plus largement
ces domaines
oui merci Madame pour votre présentation
moi je reviendrai un petit peu sur
les métiers on a découvert on fait santé
publique France au moment de
la crise sur le terrain
on connaissait les ARS on connaissait
l'action bien sûr des préfets sont-ils
plus vite France pendant un certain
temps a eu du mal à trouver sa place
dans le dispositif et je pense que vos
16 cellules régionales c'est bien mais
les régions sont très grandes et ce que
vous avez déclinaison départementale qui
est toujours là ou est-ce que vous
l'activez qu'en période de crise
j'ai l'impression que ça y est ça c'est
déjà
reperdu dans le paysage
administratif et puis quelles
conséquence vous tirez de cette crise
notamment en termes d'organisation à
mettre sur pied rapidement si un jour il
y avait une nouvelle crise alors qu'il
serait forcément différente ce sera
jamais la même et puis en ce qui
concerne les données puisque vous avez
fait effectivement des des efforts
extraordinaires il y a eu
là-dessus des innovations fantastiques
le Hells datahab qui permet justement de
concentrer un certain nombre de données
est-ce que vous vous pensez pas qu'il
faut mettre sur pied avec vos
partenaires ce que l'on avait appelé
dans un rapport sur la prospective la
crise data hub c'est à dire une
possibilité en cas de crise d'activer
différents
détenteurs de données pour pouvoir les
croiser agir déclare directement sur la
population par le numérique
ce que l'on ne sait pas forcément faire
aujourd'hui de façon plus ciblée que ça
voilà les conséquences de la crise
peuvent être de prévoir par anticipation
les futurs crises comment nous voyons
les choses quel est votre point de vue
là-dessus
c'est répondre pour compléter en effet
lorsqu'on a fait la commission d'enquête
sur la crise la crise covid dans sa
première partie puisqu'on avait commencé
en juin et on avait terminé en fin de
rendu le rapport en décembre on s'était
intéressé beaucoup au tout début de la
crise et en effet comment quand les
premiers cas est arrivé en Chine comment
l'anticipation s'était fait on avait été
c'était unanime au sein de la commission
d'enquête on n'est pas le Savary on
faisait partie
uneanime sur cette méconnaissance totale
des acteurs locaux de ce qui était santé
publique France ils connaissait les ARS
il y avait en effet des partenariats
forts entre ARS départements préfet
collectivités locales et une
méconnaissance totale de ce qui était
santé publique France donc ça c'est un
peu ça prolonge la question de hanipol
et le deuxième point c'était vous avez
beaucoup parlé de d'expertise
scientifique
on voit en plus actuellement comment la
crise a mis un doute sur la parole
scientifique on a entendu tellement de
trucs dans tous les sens des gens qui
disaient l'inverse de leurs collègues
des gens qui disaient vers un rouge un
jour et rouge le lendemain les mêmes ce
qui a donné une forme de méfiance de la
parole scientifique on avait préconisé
si vous avez le rapport une expertise
scientifique indépendante permettant de
prévoir d'anticiper de nouvelles crises
quelles qu'elles soient et on le voit
dans un sondage récent
c'est l'ifope je crois qui explique en
effet les jeunes ne croient absolument
pas la science enfin
je résume mais un pourcentage
relativement élevé de moins que c'est
qui a beaucoup augmenté ces dernières
années ne crois plus à la science ça
tient peut-être un enseignement
scientifique c'est dégradé au fil du
temps mais quel est votre regard sur
cette notion d'expertise scientifique
bien merci beaucoup je vais peut-être
déjà reprendre sur le fait que parce que
vous avez deux à le citer sur la
méconnaissance de santé publique France
au moment de la crise donc peut-être il
faut rappeler qu'effectivement santé
publique de l'écran ça création et quand
même très très récente je veux dire on
est sur 2016 donc la crise est arrivée
très peu de temps après la création de
de santé publique France site on prend
par exemple les homologues dans les
autres pays le Center des discontrol à
70 ans donc tout le monde connaît le
Sidy mais le Sidy dans sa forme actuelle
à 70 ans donc voilà donc je pense que ça
c'est le premier point santé publique
France a été pris la crise est arrivée à
un moment vous sentez plus français
était une toute toute jeune agence donc
probablement trop tôt par rapport à sa
création donc ça c'est la première chose
je pense que maintenant comme vous le
dites santé publique français connu donc
on a effectivement un devoir très
important de production scientifique de
qualité pour que effectivement à la fois
aller prendre de santé et aussi le
public puisse s'en emparer
ça c'est le premier point après vous
m'avez posé des questions sur le système
de veille sanitaire et médico-social
alors vous avez raison je pense que on a
beaucoup de systèmes de surveillance à
santé publique France mais il y en avait
aussi dans les EHPAD il y en avait en
fait qui était lié à la grippe il
existait déjà des systèmes de
surveillance dans les EHPAD et qui donc
justement a été utilisés pour faire de
la surveillance covid donc la question
c'est qu'aujourd'hui effectivement au
sortir de la crise il faut renforcer ces
systèmes de surveillance qui étaient
existants qui ont été détournés pour
faire de la surveillance du covid et il
faut effectivement les sanctuariser et
les pérenniser ça c'est une évidence on
le sait tous la population française va
vieillir donc on a un enjeu de
protection des personnes âgées et donc
de surveillance de dans toutes ces
établissements médico-sociaux qui
eux-mêmes ont été c'est avec tous les
scandales pris de plein fouet par voilà
d'autres quelques scandales n'ont pas
facilité effectivement probablement le
recueil des données
ça c'est le premier point vous m'avez
aussi évoqué donc la problématique de la
santé mentale donc juste pour appeler
vous avez raison je pense que la santé
mentale des Français au sortir de la
crise covid est une problématique et
d'ailleurs santé publique France a été
une des premières à tirer la sonnette
d'alarme et à mettre en place plusieurs
enquêtes en population générale et
notamment une enquête donc à venir sur
la santé des enfants donc de moins de 11
ans
donc cette
la santé mentale est effectivement
quelque chose qui nous préoccupe sur
lequel il va falloir pouvoir agir pour
agir il faut pouvoir surveiller donc ces
enquêtes sont essentielles et après il
faudra qu'on développe effectivement des
outils c'est vrai qu'on pourrait appeler
cette problématique de santé mentale
peut-être presque une épidémie
silencieuse donc j'en suis consciente et
je m'attacherai vraiment à ce qu'on
puisse développer des outils auprès des
populations alors quel que soit l'âge
parce que là on va regarder plus
spécifiquement les moins de 11 ans mais
on l'a vu chez les adultes aussi on a
fait un impact très net de en termes de
santé mentale de de la crise covid donc
soyez assurés que oui santé publique
française s'est emparé du sujet de santé
mentale et continuera à s'en emparer
en lien d'ailleurs avec les professeurs
de santé qui sont spécialisés d'autres
sources qui est prises en charge de la
santé mentale et notamment les
psychiatres
après vous avez une question aussi donc
sur la réserve sanitaire donc la réserve
sanitaire effectivement au cours de la
crise elle a dû déployer énormément de
personnels sur le terrain et notamment
sur le terrain d'outre-mer donc beaucoup
de réservistes ont été envoyés en
outre-mer donc la réserve sanitaire a
joué un rôle majeur c'est un outil
formidable mais qu'il faut probablement
revoir le modèle parce que au moment de
la crise il a fait les demandes ont été
multipliées par 10 par rapport à ce que
faisait la réserve sanitaire avant la
crise covid donc elle a été au
rendez-vous mais c'est clair qu'il faut
revoir son modèle probablement revoir
aussi le cadre d'emploi aussi il y a
d'autres points importants vous l'avez
souligné enfin la Cour des comptes la
souligner il y a près de 50
000 ou 60 000 personnes inscrites et
finalement on a que 7000 rés qui peuvent
être mobilisables parce qu'ils ont
rempli tout le dossier d'inscription et
finalement il n'y en a que 2000 qui vont
sur le terrain donc pourquoi une telle
différence entre les 60 000 inscrits et
les 7000 réservistes qui soient
mobilisables donc ça effectivement je
m'attacherai à essayer de comprendre et
essayer de renouveler ce vivier alors
évidemment c'est un vivier qui s'appuie
aussi sur les prochaines de santé qui
sont eux-mêmes mobilisés au quotidien là
aujourd'hui on voit bien dans la crise
que traverse l'hôpital à la médecine de
ville donc l'idée c'est de pas de
déshabiller Paul pour habiller Pierre
donc il va falloir trouver aussi
d'autres d'autres viviers et aussi de
pouvoir mobiliser la réserve sanitaire
sur pas seulement des problématiques
outre-mer mais probablement aussi des
problématiques en métropole lorsqu'il y
a une situation sanitaire exceptionnelle
un point important aussi sur la réserve
sanitaire je pense que il est même si le
modèle est perfectible il est important
aujourd'hui de rester opérationnel parce
qu'on a quand même face à nous des
enjeux alors évidemment on aura
probablement d'autres menaces émergence
mais on a aussi deux enjeux qui sont la
coupe de monde du rugby et l'accueil des
Jeux Olympiques en 2024 donc il est très
important pour santé publique France de
rester opérationnel sur le concernant la
réserve sanitaire et on verra aussi on
m'avait pas parlé vous n'avez pas évoqué
l'établissement pharmaceutique je ne
crois pas non personne ne l'a évoqué
mais je pense que de la même façon que
l'outil de la réserve sanitaire est un
outil très important
l'établissement pharmaceutique alors
venant effectivement de l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du des médicaments
des produits santé je suis évidemment
voilà je serai très attentive aux
problématiques aux évolutions de
l'établissement pharmaceutique mais
comme pour la réserve sanitaire ce sont
des outils utiles importantes en crise
on l'a vu et donc il faut absolument
qu'ils puissent rester opérationnels
dans les mois et dans les années à venir
même donc il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
rupture même si tous ces modèles sont
sont perfectibles et pour finir sur
l'établissement pharmaceutique c'est
vrai que
il y a le stock et puis il y a la
distribution et en termes de
distribution force et de constater que
l'établissement pharmaceutique a été en
capacité de distribuer des milliards de
masques et puis des millions de doses
de vaccin covit
alors après je crois que ma vie aussi
interrogé sur les cellules régionales
donc oui vous avez raison c'est
effectivement une question que on me
pose souvent parce que certains
directeurs d'agence ne sont pas
effectivement souhaiteraient récupérer
les cellules régionales au sein des ARS
alors moi je pense que c'est très
important en fait que les cellules
régionales puissent avoir un ancrage
territorial il est évident que quand on
voit les spécificités des régions il y a
des spécificités régionales et santé
publique France ne peut pas être coupée
de ces de ces territoires enfin si je
prends rien que l'autre mère entre les
problématiques chlore des connes aux
Antilles plomb en Guyane ou même l'accès
à l'eau potable ou les problèmes de
vaccination à Mayotte santé publique
France ne pas être aveugle il a besoin
il a besoin d'une représentation en
région ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point je peux comprendre par
contre que les directeurs d'arts ils
sont pas forcément tous aligné là-dessus
mais en tout cas je peux tout à fait
comprendre que au niveau des ARS se pose
la question de du fait que c'est il ait
besoin de
cellules qui soient opérationnelles pour
eux en tant que crise donc je comprends
qu'il se posent des questions là je
pense qu'on peut aussi avoir des espaces
de Diagon dialogue et de concertation et
en tout cas je m'attacherai une fois que
j'arriverai à la Direction de santé
publique France d'avoir un dialogue avec
les directeurs des ARS parce que je peux
comprendre leurs besoins et notamment en
période de crise ou ils peuvent avoir le
sentiment parfois que le temps de
l'expertise soit peut-être trop long par
rapport au temps de l'action et c'est
vrai en période de crise il faut des
circuits courts il faut aller vite donc
voilà peut-être qu'il peut y avoir des
modalités qui soient pas exactement les
mêmes en période de crise et en période
froide
voilà en tout cas c'est des choses sur
lesquelles on peut discuter avec
ah oui oui pardon effectivement
aujourd'hui il y a toujours 16 cellules
régionales c'est la même organisation
alors la crise alors non non mais vous
avez raison alors
je pense qu'effectivement une fois que
je prendrai mon poste
alors vous avez raison mais en fait les
célébrationales elles font elles font de
la crise et là on l'a bien vu que la
crise était importante mais elles sont
aussi en fait investis dans des
investigations d'épidémie et il faut pas
oublier qu'il n'y a pas il y a la
période de crise sur lequel il faut être
à la hauteur mais il y a tout le reste
et c'est un petit peu le difficile
équilibre dont je parlais tout à l'heure
qui est le show et le froid je pense il
y a aussi les cellules régionales elles
sont elles sont en première ligne pour
tout ce qui est investigation quand il y
a une épidémie elles sont en première
ligne quand il y a éventuellement une
suspicion de cluster de cancer
pédiatrique par exemple donc elles sont
vraiment très très importantes pour
faire le relais de santé publique France
sur le terrain mais en revanche je
comprends qu'en période de crise
certaines ARS puissent se poser des
questions et je voilà de toute façon
aussi
très occupé
alors de toute façon je crois qu'on
et comme vous le dit je pense que de
toute façon cette crise a été tellement
majeure et pourtant moi j'en ai fait
j'ai fait le stress en 2003 j'ai fait
bershkov en 2018 j'ai fait voler en 2014
cette crise a l'air quand même été bon
on le sait je vais pas le répéter d'une
ampleur quand même inimaginable
avec des prises de décision qu'on avait
pas connu si on peut confinement
en 2003 quand il s'agit de confiner une
de personnes c'était extrêmement
compliqué en fait on faisait une veille
on appelait matin et après midi la
personne qui était confinée pour lui
dire vous devez rester confiné etc ça
c'était en 2003 en 2020 on a réussi à
confiner la population entière vous
imaginez le chemin parcouru entre 2003
et 2020 c'est c'est stupéfiant et
peut-être aussi enfin les je pense que
c'est effectivement cet ancrage
territorial est important et d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'on peut reprocher aussi
d'ici ce qu'on peut reprocher aussi aux
agences européennes notamment au Yuk qui
peut parfois avoir une problématique de
pas d'absence d'ancrage territoriale et
juste pour faire aussi le lien avec ce
qui s'est passé dans les autres pays
sentait plus que France a été
extrêmement mobilisée et je c'est vrai
que je redis encore une fois devant la
représentation nationale je pense que je
tire mon chapeau aux travaux enfin à
l'investissement des des 700
collaborateurs de santé publique France
pendant ces trois dernières années mais
les autres agences que ça soit en
Angleterre aux États-Unis ça a été aussi
très très difficile pour eux et elles
étaient beaucoup plus nombreux que le
personnel de santé publique France
d'ailleurs le côté anglais ils ont
divisé en deux plus nombreux en effectif
à des missions pas totalement comparable
beaucoup plus nombreuses en effectifs et
l'équivalent de santé publique France au
UK en fait été dissout quelques mois
après la crise
dans mon idée simpliste sûrement compte
tenu de la crise qu'on a connu je verrai
bien organiser si on était territoires
des des périodes de de comment on
appelle ça de
d'exercice en disant voilà moi j'habite
près d'une centrale nucléaire je voulais
déjà dit 10 fois dans la commission mais
il arrive un incident faut distribuer
des cellules de machin voilà vous
devriez faire il me semble que ça
devrait être organisé parce que il y a à
la fois du ministère de l'Intérieur etc
ça doit être organisé des exercices en
période froide en période froide pour
dire voilà tant qu'il arrive ça il y
aurait demain dans un contexte mondial
quand même compliqué des gaz toxiques
qui arrivent comment on fait voilà et je
pense que on a les moyens numériques
d'avoir des cellules de crise qui
activent justement ce numérique avec la
géolocalisation les données des uns des
autres des Gafa des trucs qu'on arrive à
croiser tout ça pour pouvoir être le
plus rapide possible parce que un virus
ça vient par vague mais bon le Chine il
a mis quand même un peu de temps quand
même il y a d'autres pathogènes et qui
peuvent être beaucoup plus dangereux que
ça et arriver beaucoup plus rapidement
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait en
France un système comme ça d'exercices
comme font les pompiers qui prévoient
les incendies les choses comme ça c'est
plus compliqué dans le domaine sanitaire
ça touche toute la population et on
protège pas des biens on protège les
personnes
les pompiers aussi mais indirectement
donc voilà qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
tout ça est-ce que vous avez justement
quelque chose de précis là-dessus dans
l'organisation future vous avez raison
de citer qu'effectivement dans le cadre
de la crise covid le virus a mis quand
même quelques semaines à arriver et que
demain les menaces qu'on pourra avoir
peuvent démenas qui arrivent en quelques
heures donc c'est effectivement des
scénarios de crise qui sont à la fois
différents mais qui devraient
probablement reposer sur des
organisations qui puissent voilà être
crantés et tout à fait alors en fait là
vous je crois que c'était une des
questions il y a effectivement aussi au
niveau du ministère de la santé des
réflexions on est bien sur le rétexte de
la crise qui est de créer une direction
de la crise donc ça a été d'ailleurs à
nouveau annoncé par le ministre de la
Santé lors de ses vœux lundi dernier
donc il y a des réflexions en cours et
donc évidemment on j'y serai associé là
aujourd'hui je suis pas encore à santé
publique France mais tout à fait ça ça
fait partie des choses et des scénarios
qui sont qui sont mis sur la table parce
qu'il faut pouvoir avoir une
organisation cible qui puisse rapidement
en fait être crantée parce que c'est ça
enfin je veux dire il faut du jour au
lendemain pouvoir en quelques heures
quelques jours ou quelques semaines ça
dépend effectivement de la menace mais
dans tous les cas il faut pouvoir
cranter madame
automatiquement des dispositions
législatives au titre de la protection
des personnes des données de la CNIL etc
donc si on n'a pas cranté par
anticipation on est toujours trop tard
s'il faut reprendre des lois dans
l'urgence comme on a fait pour justement
cranter un certain nombre de choses
c'est trop tard donc c'est avant qu'il
faut voir tout ça pour prendre des
dispositions législatives à activer que
selon la gradation de crise
éventuellement préétabli qui se
produiront ou se produiront pas et
sûrement de façon différente par rapport
aux prévisions mais au moins il y a déjà
une réflexion qui permet d'être beaucoup
plus rapide alors effectivement vous
avez soulevé l'importance des données
massives je pense que c'est pour ça que
dans ma troisième priorité je me disais
donc une agence en fait qui innove je
pense qu'il faut un peu effectivement
penser autrement aller rechercher
pendant aussi de ressources chez
d'autres partenaires qui sont vraiment
des ingénieurs qui savent parfaitement
analysés des données massives je suis
pas en train de les épis biologistes
dont je fais partie ne savent pas
analyser les données mais je pense que
c'est important aussi de croiser les
compétences et ça enfin tout au long de
ma carrière je pense que j'ai vraiment
eu le souhait de pouvoir croiser les
regards et croiser les compétences et je
pense qu'effectivement c'est pour ça que
je parlais de d'ouvertures et de
d'ouvrir santé publique France encore
plus parce que le partenariat sont
indispensable mais il faut les prévoir
maintenant pour que effectivement en
période de crise tout puisse se mettre
en place
et de toute façon en période de crise
nous travaillons en étroite
collaboration avec avec le ministère de
la Santé déjà de toute façon je vais
tous les mercredis en réunion de
sécurité sanitaire mais effectivement ça
c'est voilà c'est le minimum tout à fait
mais voilà nous travaillons en étroite
collaboration avec le ministère de la
Santé vous Didier en période froide
malheureusement on n'a pas tant de
période froides que ça c'est dire que au
sortir du covid on a eu quand même la
crise montée qui était quand même
quelque chose donc finalement là
aujourd'hui 6 suis moi après on est plus
tranquille on l'était pas tout à fait
quand même en mai franchement et on a eu
la chance encore en France d'avoir le
stock des vaccins varioles qui a permis
de d'activer ça mais voilà l'épidémie ne
manquait pas que c'était quand même
quelque chose d'assez oui
moins de personnes mais c'était
ce qu'on avait ce dont on avait très
peur c'est que ça puisse effectivement
toucher une population différente avec
des enfants des adultes etc parce qu'on
sait que le manque pouvait être beaucoup
plus grave chez des enfants donc on
était quand même assez inquiet je dois
dire que la 6 mois après moi je suis
quand même beaucoup plus tranquille sur
le manquait pas mais entre-temps on a eu
aussi la triple épidémie donc
bronchiolite grippe covid c'est vrai
qu'elle était quand même d'une ampleur
et d'une précocité importante alors moi
du côté à NSM effectivement on a été
confronté aux problématiques des
pénuries mais donc voilà c'est vrai que
les crises se succèdent et donc il faut
c'est un peu le difficile équilibre
entre le choix et le froid
même quand maintenant donc la période de
froid c'est vrai de beaucoup plus
instantané que ça quoi on voit bien que
la remontée l'analyse c'est vrai que ça
prend forcément du temps mais plus c'est
loin plus ça prend du temps alors il y a
des données qui remontent très vite si
je pense effectivement aussi d'être qui
sont les dépistage
j'allais dire dépistage covid il remonte
tous les jours et donc l'idée c'est
justement le système qui a été mis en
place sur dépistage covid et puisse
basculer sur un dépistage tous les
dépenses
que vous ayez les les mains libres pour
agir
s'il vous plaît
la prévention
bon on a évoqué éventuellement les AVC
la santé des personnes âgées
sentimentales etc et un sujet qui me
tient à cœur et qu'on a pas encore
abordé c'est la prévention de l'obésité
parce que c'est vraiment un sujet majeur
de santé publique avec toutes les
incidences que ça peut avoir
comment l'agent envisage de s'emparer du
sujet pour l'instant on a un peu le
sentiment d'une certaine
dispersion en fait et des discours et
des acteurs comment l'agence pourrait
piloter cette action de prévention
alors en sur l'obésité effectivement
vous avez raison même si on a une
prévalence de l'obésité plus faible que
certains pays on est quand même à 15 au
17% donc c'est un enjeu de santé
publique
il y a une feuille de route en fait il y
a un plan obésité qui est donc mené par
le ministère et avec une personne qui a
été désignée récemment pour une feuille
de route et je suis désolée mais j'ai
oublié le nom parce que je suis pas
encore en poste instant T public France
figurez-vous je suis encore en poste à
la NSM donc oui je pense que vous avez
raison on a parlé de la santé mentale en
post covid de la santé mentale est une
problématique mais finalement l'obésité
elle est aussi en liée à cette enfin
cette cette épidémie covid elle a elle a
augmenté la sédentarité donc elle a
aggravé la santé mentale des Français
mais certainement qu'elle a aussi
aggravé la sédentarité et même si le
télétravail est une très bonne chose
elle aussi a tendance à augmenter la
sédentarité donc je suis d'accord avec
vous il faut absolument qu'on se
saisisse de ça je pense que on le fera
aussi en lien avec l'entess puisque l'on
ne cesse est quand même en charge de
toute la problématique sur
l'alimentation et vous savez que je suis
quelqu'un qui a travaillé 2 ans à
lancest donc je connais très bien les
collaborateurs de l'ancêtre et donc
j'aurais à coeur de toute façon à
travailler à travailler avec eux je peux
aussi parler du nutri-score donc qui a
été mis en place en 2017 donc
aujourd'hui on est cinq ans après il a
quand même acquis sa notoriété puisque
95% des adultes et des jeunes le
connaissent donc c'est voilà voilà donc
il est maintenant aussi accepté par les
autres pays parce qu'il y a six pays qui
ont suivi donc voilà on est on est dans
cette dynamique là qui va bien de toute
façon dans tout ce que souhaite l'Europe
qui a une politique de farm to Ford donc
de la ferme de la ferme à la fourchette
voilà j'ai cherché
simplement un mot puisque vous abordez
nutriscore évolue mais avec ses limites
je ne difficilement en tant que vraiment
mon paysan je l'ai
définitivement que
soit plus péjoratif pour un fromage que
pour une pizza vous mangez une pizza
vous mangez un bout de fromage quoi vous
mangez pas le fromage d'un coup donc il
faut que le nutriscore soit aussi adapté
à la dose qu'on va manger parce que
sinon je trouve qu'on pénalise des
produits de terroir extraordinaire
qui sont fait localement qui mangeaient
en quantité raisonnable bon à mon avis
c'est le médecin qui parle moins abîmé
la santé que de manger la pizza congelée
je ferme la parenthèse
effectivement c'est vous soulevez la
problématique de c'est pas effectivement
le détresse car il n'est pas sur une
portion mais sur un une enfin voilà en
gramme et donc vous avez on mange pas la
même quantité que de la pizza que de que
du fromage au lait cru etc donc oui mais
alors c'est difficile de trouver enfin
voilà on est obligé quand même d'avoir
un référentiel alors comme le nutrition
est justement nutri-score est sur un
référentiel scientifique on est obligé
d'avoir la même base c'est vrai que par
rapport à la vraie vie voilà c'est c'est
pas exactement la même chose mais
personne c'est pas ça ce qu'il faut voir
c'est l'intérêt pour la personne pour
nous aider alors il va falloir
bien sûr je comprends
je
comprends alors comment plus on est
déployé dans les autres pays alors on va
encore plus avoir des particularités
parce que là vous avez cité les fromages
ou les crus là je pense qu'on aura pas
trop cette problème je pense que nos
homologues européens n'auront pas trop
cette exigence sur le lait cru et je
voilà ils ont effectivement des fromages
qui n'auront qui n'auront aucun goût
mais voilà c'est un petit peu le
problème d'avoir voilà le référentiel il
peut pas il peut pas répondre à toutes
les problématiques il est une première
étape mais j'entends tout à fait ce que
vous dites et j'y suis d'autant plus
sensible que mes deux ans allant de ces
je me suis beaucoup rapprochée du milieu
agricole des cultivateurs
c'est une sensibilisation pour
aller vers une meilleure alimentation il
me semble qu'il y a quelque chose qui
est relativement simple à mettre en
place y compris dans le cadre du
nutrisccor c'est la teneur en matière
grasse ou en selle sur une portion
alors elle y est souvent d'ailleurs
normalement mais pas assez mis en
évidence vous trouvez donc de toute
façon vous enfin tout est perfectible je
veux dire en termes d'alimentation on a
encore beaucoup beaucoup d'enjeux et
qui crée trop gras c'est des choses
assez simples
on le voit bien quand vous cuisine ou
quand on consomme sans aller jusqu'à
regarder quel sortait moi j'avais une
question c'était on parle de
réorganisation du ministère
est-ce que vous serez impliqué ou est-ce
que
parce que vous êtes toutes les semaines
au ministre donc est-ce que vous serez
appliqué dans la réorganisation c'est
vraiment vous êtes en parallèle et c'est
votre ministère de tutelle alors oui
vous le rappelez c'est effectivement
notre seul ministère de tutelle
effectivement la santé donc de toute
façon oui les agences sont de toute
façon consulter là j'en suis dans une
phase un petit peu entre deux parce que
je suis à la NSM pas encore sentie
publique France mais oui évidemment tout
ça se fait en concertation et pas dans
le cas de la réunion de sécurité
sanitaire du mercredi matin mais
effectivement dans d'autres cas mais oui
oui je peux vous confirmer que
évidemment les agents sont partis
prenantes
on est d'accord
quand on doit gérer des crises je suis
pas sûr que ce soit légitime que ce soit
votre seul ministère de tutelle parce
qu'en période de crise vont perdez la
main à ce moment-là oui mais vous perdez
la main à ce moment-là c'est comment la
crise ça gère plutôt me semble-t-il avec
le ministère de l'Intérieur qui a un
savoir-faire quand même
de toute façon on n'a pas la prétention
avec cette 100 personnes de gérer la fin
700 personnes qui ne font pas du tout
que de la crise on n'a pas la prétention
de gérer la crise et je pense que de
toute façon toute crise se gère en
raison en partenariat et c'est tout
l'important c'est effectivement d'avoir
organisé le réseau et pouvoir cranter
donc nous nous sommes effectivement
partenaires de tout ça et on alimente
effectivement avec
à la voilà des données robustes et de
l'expertise qui
dans le cas de contribution aux travaux
du SCSP de la chas et aussi beaucoup et
ça se voit pas forcément sur notre site
au travers de notes on fait énormément
de notes qui sont destinées au ministère
de la Santé pour les éclairer
santé publique alors tout à fait je suis
pas encore en poste mais c'est vrai que
de toute façon effectivement il existe
depuis très longtemps et on fait comme
si
il existe le
café effectivement il y a beaucoup de
collaboration entre santé publique
France et toutes les agences
équivalentes au travers de l'oeil au
pencie d'ici un peu comme la NSM au
travers de l'Agence européenne du
médicament et puis il y a aussi en fait
un réseau des agences sanitaires dont
j'ai oublié l'acronyme excusez-moi c'est
un acronyme à quatre lettres et je ne
l'ai plus en tête mais en tout cas santé
publique France et héberge le
secrétariat de de ce collectif de toutes
les agences de santé publique
internationale et donc ça je pense que
c'est effectivement quelque chose de
très important et je pense aussi que
alors il faut aussi savoir que au
conseil scientifique il est présidé par
en anglais qui est un ancien qui est un
ancien de de l'agence
de l'agence anglaise donc voilà ça crée
des liens le conseil scientifique à
santé publique France c'est composé d'un
tiers de personnes
dont beaucoup d'anglais qui occupaient
des postes importants dans l'équivalent
de santé publique France au UK
oui parce que j'étais un peu mouette là
madame la Présidente je voulais
simplement remercier Madame de nous
avoir fait partager d'une part
l'ensemble de votre parcours de nous
montrer votre enthousiasme aussi à la
suite des questions qui vous ont été
posées on sent que il y a une envie
voilà d'intégrer en tout cas cette
structure désormais en tout cas à sa
tête et voilà j'ai senti qu'il y avait
vraiment de la pétance je vous remercie
mon attention c'est toujours porté sur
la transparence des moyens qui ont été
donnés à l'agence santé publique France
donc aujourd'hui je vais pas vous
embêter avec ça j'ai pas l'intention de
vous ennuyer avec les chiffres mais
c'est vrai que pendant la crise covid il
y a eu quand même des montants
substantiels et que ce qu'on a souhaité
en demandant à la Cour des comptes de se
pencher sur le sujet c'est c'est surtout
a besoin de transparence mais vous
parliez des des
commandes des rapprochements avec la
population en tout cas avec
les associations de patients mais les
associations de patients des
associations quelles qu'elles soient de
la population puisqu'on on doit avoir
justement ce ces échanges assez assez
forts désormais pour voir ce qu'ils
attendent ils attendent aussi beaucoup
de transparence sur le plan financier
donc moi je
m'arrêterai à juste cette petite
intention si vous pouviez communiquer
sur effectivement les dépenses les
recettes de l'agence et que chacun
puisse voir où vont l'argent des
Français c'est parfait en tout cas moi
ça me conviendra très bien merci Madame
et bien effectivement on a bien pris
note et on en a discuté déjà avec
Marianne Jacquet on est tout à fait
d'accord évidemment c'est vrai que c'est
des sommes assez importantes on parle de
plus de 4 milliards
4 milliards au moment de la crise mais
maintenant il est redescendu alors il
est en fonction socle plutôt autour de
200 millions effectivement les 4
milliards c'était pour évidemment oui ça
fait une belle chute mais si on achète
plus de vaccins covid ça nous permet de
faire beaucoup d'économies parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a plus été très cher
c'est les masques et les vaccins ARS il
était tout à fait
les tests
à côté des 4 milliards je suis d'accord
merci beaucoup Julien merci beaucoup de
cette échange et on vous souhaite d'être
nommé à la tête de cette de cette agence
importante dans le système de santé
merci beaucoup à bientôt on aura
l'occasion de la commission merci
beaucoup